melania trump auf dem weg zur wahlurne
in palm beach florida gibt die first
lady ihre stimme am dienstagvormittag ab
ob der elegante auftritt die wähler in
dem swing state of trance seite zieht
style technisch gibt milan ja zumindest
alles nicht 50 nicht 500 stolze 4500
dollar kostet das kleid von gucci mit
dem typischen ketten print was für ein
auftritt die wahlbeteiligung dürfte
dadurch jedoch nicht steigen stolze 45
minuten lang war das wahllokal für
ottonormal amerikaner geschlossen aus
sicherheitsgründen sind es ist das ein
auftritt lena alex der eine band wo man
draufkommt mehr interesse ist das für
ein kleid für den man sich begeistert
oder schon toll aus aber wieder kein
charisma wir lagen ja hat das hat das
talent die tollsten kleider zu tragen
perfekt auszusehen und nicht so rüber zu
bringen
und deswegen glaube ich immer dass man
menschen teufel die einzigartig sind und
nicht die schön sind das sieht man am la
maison keine sorgen machen keine massen
zimmer mit lande bist du total
zurückhaltend
ich suche war ein moment warum suchen
momentan nämlich schweigen kann das gar
nicht mehr da ist man ja ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt zu wenig um sie um um
eine große mine und sie sagen was ich
bei ich finde ich habe neulich in rhede
von ihr gehört in florida
da ist sie vor ihrem mann aufgetreten
und hat eine rede gehalten
ich hab nicht wirklich verstanden ich
war erstmal erstmal er verdutzt wie wie
schlecht sie englisch spricht ehrlich
gesagt und dabei habe ich mir auch
gedacht haben die wie cool das duell als
first lady dort stehst und mit einem
schweren osteuropäischen akzent
radebrechen englisch spricht viele ich
bin überzeugt viele einwanderer aus
polen und ich weiß nicht woher die in
amerika leben irgendwann in new york
sind und die die die als zweite sprache
dann polnisch sprechen und auch oder
slowakischer hier gibt es in große
die seen zu mir und sagen das ist eine
amerikanerin wie wir sie spricht zwar
kein englisch quasi aber sie ist mehr an
dreht sich ist nicht nur amerikanerin
sie ist die first lady ich glaube ich
glaube dass dieser kleine kurze
wahlkampfauftritt von ihr stimmen gibt
aber wir lernen jetzt also genau die art
von einem anderen die dort nicht haben
wenn sie spricht die sprache noch immer
nicht so richtig gut ist es genauso wie
donald trump ist dann eigentlich alles
ein bisschen zu polemik aber ich dachte
das muss schon sagen das ist schon jetzt
weiße haus ist doppelt so viel weiß
nicht wie wir wollen das natürlich
ändern weil wir haben den ort besuch von
dem melania trump tatsächlich kommt sie
kommt er hier aus europa und unsere
kollegen waren also an ihrem geburtsort
einmal auf den spuren der kindheit von
melania trump
[Musik]
maine has been donnerstag
sie ist die ehefrau des mächtigsten
mannes der welt sie ist die frau des
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
unser 2017 lady und sie kommt aus europa
melania ein mädchen aus einfachsten
verhältnissen ist nun die bekannteste
frau im land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten
[Applaus]
ihre geschichte ist die eines
slowenischen aschenputtels dieses weiße
haus geschafft hat und damit den
american dream liegt melania trump
hier sind in china in ihrer heimatstadt
und wollen wissen wer war melania bevor
sie zur jump wurde zu begeben uns auf
spurensuche
der ort aus dem die heutige first lady
stammt liegt knapp 6600 kilometer von
washington dc die slowenische kleinstadt
ionita hat gerade mal 6000 einwohner
wir besuchen ihr alters wird eine
sozialistische platten siedlung als
melania hier aufwuchs regierte präsident
josip tito und die slowenische
kleinstadt gehörte zum kommunistischen
jugoslawien hier im dritten stock des
hauses hinter dieser tür befindet sich
die kleine drei zimmer wohnung mit
balkon in der melania trump ihre ersten
jahre des lebens gemeinsam mit ihrer
familie damals noch melania knauss
verbracht hat wir haben auch schon
versucht mit der familie die jetzt dort
gelebt zu sprechen aber vor der kamera
möchte sich hier keiner mehr äußern es
gab einfach schon zu viel
vier jahre nach der wahl zur first lady
und unzähligen besuchen von journalisten
möchten nur noch wenige menschen über
melania sprechen
eine nachbarin erbarmt sich
schließlich treffen wir einen freund der
familie
aloys sasac der 66 jährige sieht melanie
als vater victor noch heute wenn er
seine heimat besucht als slowene bin ich
echt stolz auf sie sie war meine
nachbarin da hinten im anderen blog ihre
familie waren ganz einfache leute sie
haben viel gearbeitet also eine ganz
normale familie
früher war es ganz normal hier in so
einem blog zu wohnen als die kinder dann
größer wurden sind sie in ein
einfamilienhaus gezogen von der platte
ins weiße haus
zumindest erstmal in das ihrer eltern
das gehört familie klaus übrigens noch
heute
doch mittlerweile leben sie mit den
trumps in new york melanie als vater
victor knaus handelte damals mit autos
und motorrädern
ihre mutter amalia arbeitete in der
textilfabrik weshalb melania schon zu
schulzeiten mit der modewelt in
berührung kamen sogar schon erste lokale
modenschauen im alter von sieben jahren
lief ihre professionelle modelkarriere
beginnt sie in der slowenischen
hauptstadt mit 17 jahren zieht melania
nach julian wir sind auf der spurensuche
und treffen model fotograf spanier
kommen der 83-jährige gewährt uns
einblicke in sein kleines milani archiv
seine fotos brachten die damalige
studentin auf die titelseiten der
modewelt noch heute schwärmt er von der
slowenischen schönheit
ich habe sofort gesehen ihre figur ihr
gesicht ihre haare und augen haben model
potenzial
ich habe bei so vielen wettbewerben
schon nach models zum fotografieren
gesucht keine war so wie sie
ich habe sie auf der straße entdeckt
hier diese bilder das sind die ersten
ein jahr lang haben der fotograf und die
heute 50-jährige zusammen gearbeitet
dann bekam melania ein angebot aus
mailand und eroberte die mode viele
menschen und auch amerikaner haben wir
gesagt dass mir lagen ja ihren erfolg
mir zu verdanken hat da ich ihre ersten
bilder gemacht und sie in die modewelt
gebracht habe und jemand anderes sie
fotografiert hätte hätte sie vielleicht
nicht dieselbe chance so bekommen
aber wer weiß das schon so genau
vielleicht hat sie einen teil ihres
erfolges mir zu verdanken
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr stolz sie
entdeckt zu haben
sie ist die first lady und eine
modeikone ich bin wirklich stolz
[Musik]
von den laufstegen in mailand paris und
london bis nach new york city 1995
beginnt model melania ihre laufsteg
karriere im big apple
zwei jahre später lernt sie auf einer
fashion week party immobilien tycoon
donald trump can 2005 heiraten das model
und der milliardär
ein jahr später kommt sohn barron zur
welt das einfache mädchen ist ganz oben
angekommen und das macht die menschen in
ihrer slowenischen heimat juni zu stolz
so stolz dass man mit melania im
örtlichen tourismus center sogar richtig
geschäfte macht ja also das ist unser
first lady melania kollektion wir haben
wein schokolade krems und vieh verkaufen
sich die produkte gut
nun ja es sind keine massen aber es
verkauft sich ok melania gibt es
übrigens auch noch als salami
und es gibt noch mehr im ort steht sogar
ein abbild der first lady in bronze
gegossen
das vorgänger modell aus holz viel einem
brandanschlag zum opfer
der künstler und melania fan alles maxi
lopez lässt sich von trump gegner nicht
entmutigen
wissen sie es ist doch so einige mögen
die kunst andere nicht was passiert ist
ist passiert
ich bin immer noch sehr stolz darauf auf
die statue und auf die first lady aber
geschmäcker sind verschieden
einige loben die neue statue andere
nicht
es ist wie im momentanen us wahlkampf
und auch in der korona politik die
gemüter sind gespalten
[Musik]
und dass es aktuell das weiße haus ums
weiße haus geht es heute in wenigen
stunden wissen wir ob johnny chan
us-präsident bleibt oder ob da ein neuer
präsident in dieses zentrum der macht
einzieht und wir haben gerade gesehen
dass wir bei den wurzeln von melani
warnt das war jasmin die sie dort
besucht hat beziehungsweise ihre
ehemaligen nachbarn besucht hat ihre
angehörigen besucht hat und so weiter
und so fort
neben uns noch ein bisschen mit was ist
dass dafür ein kaff in slowenien und wie
respektvoll oder vielleicht auch nicht
redet man heute über mail an ja ja also
kaufmann cup kann man es auf jeden fall
in 6000 seelen ort in slowenien so eine
stunde von der hauptstadt entfernt ein
sehr ruhiges beschauliches örtchen in
dem melania dort aufgewachsen ist also
hat vielleicht auch noch eben in der maz
ja gesehen
sie ist in so einem seiner typischen
platten siedlungen sozialistischen bau
groß geworden also kommt aus sehr
einfachen verhältnissen keine ärmlichen
verhältnisse aber doch er hat das leben
heute oder ihr leben heute mit dem von
damals natürlich überhaupt nichts mehr
zu tun also sozusagen ist es so ein
aschenputtel märchen schon fast der
amerikanische traum ja dann doch sie
kommt - sie sind einfach verein ist
jetzt liebt sie gab es gerade gesehen
das weiße haus das ist jetzt ihre heimat
gibt es auch nicht wenn die menschen
über sie sprechen oder ist das nur
voller stolz dass man mit ihr zusammen
aufgewachsen ist dass man sie kennt wie
es da wie ist also die stimmung wie
blickt man jetzt auf die heutige melania
also vor vier jahren als melania zur
first lady wurde und trampe eben zum
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
wurde gab es ein total hype in dieser
stadt
das ist jetzt mittlerweile so ein
bisschen abgeflacht man sehr genau also
man hat natürlich in den vier jahren
waren über 80 90 journalisten aus der
ganzen welt
irgendwie da und haben natürlich
versucht mit den nachbarn zu reden mit
alten schulfreunden zu reden gibt es ja
nicht so gerne borat figur im dorf zu
sagen hey des dorfes ist ein ganz ganz
begeistert ist dass leute mit der kamera
kommen freunde von milliarden damit ihr
auch ausgegraben sind wir da noch dran
ex-freunde dunkle geschichten über also
tatsächlich da überhaupt nicht gefunden
die also es sind ja natürlich auch viele
aus dem ort weggezogen irgendwie in die
hauptstadt und haben sich dort eben
gerettet aber nochmal um darauf
zurückzukommen also die im ort sind
natürlich schon irgendwie genervt davon
über melania zu reden weil sie natürlich
nicht das einzige aushängeschild sein
soll für diesen kleinen ort also wir
haben immer wieder die türen der
tourismusmanager hat uns erzählt na wir
haben doch auch schöne berge wir haben
doch auch ein tolles schloss was man
besuchen kann also melania als
aushängeschild irgendwie für diese ganze
stadt zu nehmen ist so ein bisschen na
da sind sie so ein bisschen drüber
trotzdem auf der anderen seite haben
natürlich auf viele erzählt wir sind
irgendwo auch stolz mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren